are you introverted looking for a job
and trying to network this videos for
you
hey there welcome back this is episode
20 of Udacity career tips my name is
Martin McGovern and today we are
discussing how to network like an
introvert that's right I said network
like an introvert because being an
introvert is not inherently a bad thing
when it comes to building robust network
it just means that you might use
different tools than your extroverted
counterparts let's look at the stats 80%
of the population is shy or used to be
shy leaving only 20% of the population
feeling as though they're an outgoing
Bunch
now you can find me in the 40% in the
middle who used to be shy but have
overcome that shyness however this
doesn't mean that I'm not still
sometimes a Wallflower at a networking
event as a matter of fact one of the
things that I love so much about making
videos like these is I get to stay in
touch with lots of people from the
comfort of my computer which brings us
to introvert networking tactic number
one create content while extroverts are
out there shaking hands and kissing
babies
a powerful introvert is creating content
and sharing their interests online
starting a blog podcast YouTube channel
or something along those lines might
seem like an extrovert game but the
truth is you are in full control of the
content you put out and you can do it
all on your own if you want the tools
are available and if you do it right and
get a little bit of traction you'll find
that people will start coming to you
rather than you having to go track
others down it really is a great way to
network at scale onto introvert
networking tactic number two interact
online creating content is the best way
for you to put yourself out in front of
people share your interests and showcase
your abilities if you're not at this
stage yet what you can do is become a
curator of content for your industry you
can share other people's ideas maybe
give some commentary and then comment on
other people's posts all over the
Internet every time you like a photo
comment on a post share an article
answer a question or do anything that is
engaging with the online algorithm you
are micro
working these numerous touch points over
time help keep you top of mind and help
keep others in your network who might
otherwise fall off this is also a
massive value add to anyone who creates
content because every time they post
something new they are praying that
other people will like comment and share
their brilliant ideas so pick your
social network or a combination of a few
and get to work commenting on
conversations that are related to your
career goals
finally introvert networking tactic
number three collaborate with extroverts
one of my first side hustles was a
networking group that I started with a
good friend from college at the time I
struggled even sending an email to a
stranger without having a panic attack
while he worked in sales and was happy
to walk up to strangers on the street
and just say hello when we partnered up
I decided to take on all the backend
responsibilities creating our logo all
the event pages our website etc and he
took over all the front-end
responsibilities like figuring out
catering reaching out to venues and
finding speakers for our events the
pairing was mutually beneficial and we
were able to accomplish so much more
together than we ever could on our own
so if you're really feeling stuck reach
out to an extrovert in your life who you
know pretty well and see if they can
help
now I put the question back to you which
of these three introvert networking
tactics do you like the most and which
are you going to try let me know in the
comments thank you so much for watching
if you know someone who's searching for
a job right now
tag them below good luck in your job
search and I'll be seeing you on the
next career tip